et en plateau à présent vous l'avez
aperçu Fran doos bonsoir à vous et
bienvenue je vous laisse finir de vous
installer et on va parler avec vous
bûche de Noël deux journalistes de la
rédaction chose promise chose du bonsoir
Valérie bonsoir Anthon
bonsoir pour nous parler solidarité de
Noël donc oui tout à fait B je je vais
commencer oui Franck de Bos vient juste
d'arriver il nous a apporté de très très
bonnes choses à déguster mais on va
encore attendre un peu je sais que
Wilfried vous vous êtes impatient depuis
ce mi la cuillère est dans la poche mais
donc voilà vous avez fait votre
traditionnel le bûche de fin d'année
bûche de Noël et donc du coup on pourra
on pourra déguster tout ça et parler de
tout ça tout à l'heure et on parlera
solidarité aussi Valérie oui solidarité
car on va tous déguster la bûche mais
pas seulement nous allons parler aussi
des Pères Noël vert he de du Secours
populaire qui agissent depuis 36 ans
hein depuis
1976 qu'ils sont créés et pour en parler
avec nous parcal Rodier bonjour vous
êtes secrétaire général de la Fédération
du Secours populaire des Yvelines alors
quelles sont les les actions que vous
organisez chaque année au moment des
fêtes avec les Pères Noël verts
justement alors en fait l'idée c'est que
Noël n'oublie personne que le Père Noël
rouge visiblement de plus en plus occupé
donc le Père Noël vert lui donne un coup
de main pour être sûr de passer dans le
plus de foyers possible donc tous les
bénévoles se mobilisent pour collecter
des fonds déjà parce que c'est quand
même le nerd de la solidarité pas que de
la guerre donc on collecte beaucoup de
fond pour pouvoir
après constituer des collines Noël pour
les personnes défavorisées du
département et puis aussi organiser des
braderies de jouet des des sorties au
spectacle aujourd'hui il y avait une
sortie à la il y une sortie sur à la
patinoire il y a des sorties au cirque
pour que chacun puisse bénéficier un
petit peu du du temps de Noël donc voilà
on est un petit peu occupé je dois dire
d'accord alors comment peut-on donner au
Secours populaire aujourd'hui quels sont
les dons dont vous avez besoin alors
comme j'ai dit tout à l'heure le le nerf
de la solidarité reste l'argent pour
vous donner un ordre d'idée pour le
libre service de Noël on a quand même
dépensé un petit peu moins de 15000 €
pour acheter des des denrées un peu
festives donc pour ça il faut des sous
hein il faut pas que des paquets de
pâtes même si c'est utile pour donner à
manger aux gens donc d'abord de l'argent
donc en faisant un don à la structure du
Secours populaire la plus proche de chez
soi ou sur internet on va sur on fait
sec cours populaire 78
spf78.org et on doit pouvoir trouver
assez facilement on clique sur donner et
il y a pas de souci on arrive à donner
facilement et puis euh est-ce que les
gens ont donné justement pour l'instant
cette année les gens ont étaé solidaire
parour de la crise on voit sur certains
événements comme le Téléton où les dons
sont en léger reculou ouis bah nous en
fait je dois dire merci aux donateurs
parce que on on connaî pas la crise dans
les deux sens enfin je veux dire on la
connaît pas en nombre de de personnes
qui viennent nous voir mais
malheureusement pour eux c'est la crise
nous on n'est pas en sousactivité c'est
en augmentation de 5 % par rapport à
l'an dernier au niveau des bénéficiaires
pour les bénéficiaires de Noël oui on
est passé à 1800 familles ça fait quand
même la bagatelle de 7200 et quelques
personnes au sein des ivelines parle
dans l'ensemble des ivelines oui ou oui
dans l'ensemble des ivelines et la
l'accroissement moyen est entre 5 et 10
% depuis 3 4 ans maintenant alors on a
la chance d'être quand même dans un
département relativement riche et donc
les dons affluent malgré tout malgré la
la crise donc B faut savoir que le
département des Yveline c'est le
département de France où l'écart est le
plus grand entre les plus riches et les
plus le département en France où il y a
plus de disparités entre les plus riches
et les plus pauvres alors il se trouve
qu'effectivement on a quand même des des
personnes qui sont très généreuses on a
reçu un le don d'un donateur particulier
de 3000 € par
exemple un donateur de Montin Bretonneux
dont je ne citerai pas le nom mais il se
reconnaîtra s s'il regarde TVfil donc
voilà il a il y a effectivement encore
beaucoup de gens très généreux et puis
il y a aussi des gens qui donnent même 2
€ 1 € et tout ça finit par donner les
moyens pour faire la solidarité il y a
pas de les petits comme les gros dons
restent des dons et ils sont utiles d'
alors des moyens vous en aurez encore
besoin pour le dernier weekend des des
fêtes hein pour pour plus de bénévoles
encore alors en fait on recherche des
bénvole encore pour le dernier
weekend ça fait plusieurs années qu'on
est à vis 2 et on met en paquet cadeau
pour une marque enfin je vais pas je
vais pas la citer mais c'est un produit
de distribution produit
culturel ça donne déjà pas mal
d'indication on met on met tout ça en
pochette et en fait les les les
particuliers sont invités à soutenir le
Secours populaire en donnant une pièce
ou un billet les billets sont aussi
acceptés il y a pas de souci et tout ça
bah ça nous permet de de financer tout
ce que je vous disais tout à l'heure
quoi puis il y a des chaînes de
solidarité qui s'organisent dès l'école
on a un centre scolaire de voisin de
Bretonneux qui a organisé un marché de
Noël le la semaine dernière et les
recettes du du du marché de Noël donc
c'est l'école du bois de la Garenne à
voisin Bretonneux bah les les parents
les enfants sont mobilisés tous tout un
tas de produits ont été vendus entre
parents aux enfants et tout ça et les
recettes fond de la solidarité pour le
coup là ça se passe au Niger les enfants
vont contribuer au financement de
pépinière au Niger donc ça permet
d'allier le temps de Noël à une
solidarité y compris au-delà des
frontières parfait bien merci puis alors
voilà ne pas oublier les voilà les des P
noëvert on pense sec secs populaire VO
exactement ça rime en plus fait pour
pensez bien c'est fait pour restez avec
nous Pascal Rudier quelques instants i
je voyais lorer un petit peu sur les
macarons et sur la bûche de Noël on va
parler pâtisserie dans un instant on
reste dans le vert en tout cas pour le
moment plutôt du côté environnement
recyclage avec un atelier drôle d'ange à
la Maison de l'Environnement et c'est à
manilamo un atelier pour apprendre à
réaliser des décorations de Noël avec
des matériaux recyclés bouchons sac
plastique et fil de fer est-ce que c'est
joli ou pas on va voir
ça too montre son ange qu'il a fabriqué
tout seul sous le regard de son frère et
de sa maman cette famille a participer à
l'atelier drôle d'ange à la Maison de
l'Environnement à Manil et àameau des
réalisations de décoration de en matière
recyclé et les enfants n'ont pas manqué
d'imagination j'ai déjà fait ange comme
les autres sauf que j'ai rajouter des
pieds et des boutons le corps je l' fait
en carton au lieu de faire des a en
carton et les Aes je les fait
en
plastique de faire le corps en plastique
on va les accrocher et puis on va mettre
de la laine je pense qu'on va continuer
la maison on va rajouter des choses des
couleurs peut-être voilà comme il
veulent ce côté là maintenant parce que
là il y en a de ce côté mais pas de des
traits comme
ça très bien on doit transformer la
matière première en fait en la
redécoupant on utilise que du les
ciseaux et des liens pour fixer on n pas
de colle et de ça donc voilà c'était un
peu le but aussi de se débrouiller sans
col sans scotch à leur disposition des
bouchons en plastique des assiettes en
carton du fil de fer et du sac plastique
l'objet premier une façon écologique de
concevoir décoration de
fête alors vous disiez sur les
décorations de Noël ça vous a plu ou
pas allez-y allez-y parce que tout le
monde a rigolé quand je dit est-ce que
c'est joli ou pas voilà on m'a dit oh là
là il faut pas dire ça alors vous pense
c'est quoiah c'est de l'art donc c'est
facile les goû les couleurs comme ça
c'est
réglé tour de table non décation moi
j'ai plutôt bouché sur la bûche mais en
fait un peu par les macarons en fait
voilà faut l'avouer on était dans
l'organisation de la table pour mettre
en alure les les beaux macarons et la
belle bûche qui donne bien envie même
dans le recyclage encore quelques
instants oui puisqu'on va regarder un
reportage sur une société maniquoise qui
justement met le sapin enfin recycle les
sapins vous allez voir c'est Anthony qui
a qui a écrit le reportage on regarde
tout ce que ça
donne comment ne pas fêter Noël sans le
traditionnel sapin habillé de ses boules
saintillantes et autres guirlandes
électriques dans cette entreprise de
Manil et Hau les arbres les plus
originaux pourraient investir votre
salon cela va du sapin en bois au plus
surprenant le sapin spiral peut-être le
conifère du futur sans oublier le modèle
en plastique recyclé fabriqué par une
entreprise de trappe son design permet
de faire passer les traditionnelles
guirlandes à travers ses trous le
principe de des sapins en plastique
recyclé c'est fait par des matières à 80
% recyclé et on a fait un design
spécifique coupé au laser pour
pouvoir les utiliser dans les dans les
entreprises cet aspect développement
durable l'entreprise cquantinoise y est
très attachée verdeco récupère l'eau de
pluie pour arroser les plantes de la
serre un espace alimenté par des
panneaux photovoltaïque et chauffé
entièrement par une chaudière à bois
contrairement à ce qu'on P on peut
penser c'est une une politique qui est
gagnante je vais citer par exemple les
déchets verts donc nous on retraite
l'ensemble de nos déchets verts au lieu
que ça devienne un coût pour
l'entreprise c'est un gain puisquon
revend le compost que l'on produit tous
les ans pour vous offrir ces sapins
nouvelle génération il vous faudra
débourser tout de même entre 240 et 450
€